[Music]
you wanted to see me sir
soundcard thank you coach i prefer to
stand
all right go ahead then
tell me
tell you what
why a team worth 800 million dollars one
of the most complex offenses ever built
should put you in the driver's seat
you're too old to be working too green
to be a pro
[Music]
so why in the world would i give you
this shot
[Music]
all my life
i've defined myself through sports
i've always come up empty
coach i can win for you you need to
start thinking about life after football
son
we gave you the chance
we're letting you go
i was meant for something
something more
you think you could be that guy
yeah i do
what are you doing here
i wasn't ready for it
but i am now
you define all thoughts
i know who i am
i know why i'm here
if you give me a chance green went down
hard and is not getting up
i will not let you down
[Music]
something special about you son
destiny
remarks that the underdogs
you want to prove that
[Music]
[Music]
you